The first thing I would say,
and I do tell parents this has just
figure out what it is that their kid is
interested in.
Um,
and also what are the kinds of things
that they may be struggling with.
So if there's a child that is,
I'm struggling with,
um,
a certain way of conceiving of complex
problems.
So maybe they're struggling in math a
little bit.
There is a lot of different kinds of
games that give kids practice in a
ordering certain kinds of problems
working through kinds of certain
sequences of logic.
Maybe there's a kid that has a passion
around sports.
Sports Games are a great opportunity for
them to get in there and play with their
friends,
but also gained some facility around the
technology.
Um,
and so it mostly has to do with trying
to match an interest that their child
might have with,
um,
one a game might be offering,
not just in terms of content but also in
the type of game.
So if you have a kid that is,
let's say,
really interested in,
and I'll go back to the math and
engineering.
There's a whole genre of games about
building stuff that might be a great job
of game for that kid.
Um,
there may be a kid that's really
interested,
very detail oriented type a personality
kid a real time strategy.
Games are a great genera of games for
those kids and those are games where you
are managing complex sets of resources
in a simulation environment and try to
advance toward a particular kind of
goal.
Maybe you have a kid that's really
creative and interested in more open
ended kind of exploration.
There's a whole genre of adventure
games,
um,
that might be really good for that
particular kind of child.
Um,
so just really has to do with what the
situation is.
Well,
the most important thing we know from a
learning perspective is um,
talk.
So kids that grow up in households where
they don't have an opportunity to talk
with parents about what they're doing.
Um,
the kids tend to struggle in many ways
because they haven't again,
been given the opportunity to practice
with the language,
with using words,
with putting together a complex ideas
with creating arguments.
So the,
the simplest and biggest thing a parent
can do with a child is sit down and play
with them,
play the game with them,
talked to them about what they're doing,
prompt them,
ask them questions.
A kids love it when the parent asks them
to show that the kid will show the
parent how to do something.
Um,
we have,
uh,
a program at the Institute of play
called play force where we bring in kids
from third grade up until college and
they play test games for us and they,
um,
tell us what they think are valuable
about the games and what we found is
with some of the younger kids that the
moms started coming in with the kids and
they would sit next to him and start to
play.
And there was um,
a radical change in the relationship
between the parents understanding of
what their kids were learning from these
games and be just in the relationship
between that parent and child as the
child became an expert in explaining to
the mom what they were doing,
what they were learning how to play the
game.
Um,
and so that's a really powerful role
that you can put your child in,
um,
is letting them be the teacher and
letting them share with you what it is
that they find so interesting about this
thing that they're doing.
And it has consequences in terms of
their potential for future learning.